Speaker 1: There are basic fundamental questions
that have to be asked of every elected official,
and they often are not being asked. And
a British Sky News journalist confronted
Texas Republican Senator Ted Cruz yesterday and
asked him very obvious and specific questions
about the gun violence problem in the United
States. Ted Cruz didn't like it. He accused
the guy of playing politics and he walked
away. Sky News is no left wing bomb throwing
network. Sky News is the British version of
Fox News. Let's take a look at what happened.
Speaker 6: And not unwelcome.
Speaker 4: There. 19 sets of parents.
You're never going to get to
kiss their child tonight again.
Speaker 6: Is this the moment to reform gun laws?
Speaker 4: You know, it's easy to go to politics.
Speaker 6: But it's important.
Speaker 1: To by the way, this is a this
is a focus group tested technique. If anyone ever
brings up gun policy, you pejoratively say that
that's politics. That's politics. And politics
is bad and it's the wrong time for politics.
This is just a tool. It's a crutch that they use.
But the reporter is not going to be dissuaded.
Speaker 6: The heart of the issue.
Speaker 4: I get that. That's
where the media likes to go.
Speaker 1: And so that's the
second layer of the attack. Ted Cruz is doing
all the right things from the point of view of
Republican disinformation. If anyone asks about
guns, you call it politics. If they press you,
you say this is what the media likes to do because
the media is bad if you're a Republican. Okay. But
the reporter is not going to be dissuaded.
Speaker 6: It's not. It's where many of the
people we've talked to here like to go.
Speaker 4: The proposals from Democrats
in the media, inevitably, when some
violent psychopath murders people.
Speaker 6: A violent psychopath
who's able to get a weapon so easily,
18 year old with to a AR 15 if.
Speaker 4: You want to stop
violent crime. The proposals the Democrats
have, none of them would have stopped this.
Speaker 1: Well, actually, I gave a list of ten
ideas at the top of the show, four of which would
have potentially had an impact in this particular
case. But they don't want to try any of them.
Speaker 6: Why does this only happen in
your country? I really think that's what
many people around the world just they
cannot fathom. Why only in America why
is this American exceptionalism so awful?
Speaker 4: You know, I'm sorry. You think
American exceptionalism is awful?
Speaker 6: I think
this aspect I think this aspect of it.
Speaker 4: You get your political agenda.
Speaker 1: Yeah. The political agenda of right
wing Sky News, the British version of Fox. I mean,
truly a pathetic coward.
Speaker 6: I'd love you,
Senator. It's not. I just want to understand
why you do not think that guns are the problem.
Speaker 7: Why is this just an American problem?
Speaker 1: Now another reporter jumps in.
Speaker 6: It is just an American problem, sir.
Speaker 7: Mr. Cruz, why is America the only
country that faces this kind of.
Speaker 4: You know.
Speaker 2: What? Mass shooting.
Speaker 6: But you can't answer
that. You can't answer that, can you? So
you can't answer that. Why is this why.
Speaker 4: Is it that people come from.
Speaker 1: By the way, now he starts
pointing at the guy's chest with the finger all.
Speaker 4: Over the world to America because it's
the freest, most prosperous, safest.
Speaker 3: Country, maybe and maybe.
Speaker 6: The freest, maybe the most.
Speaker 2: Poor, poor kids dying.
Speaker 6: And if they got clear enough,
the governors earlier news conference.
Speaker 1: Yeah. When is the time for
politics? Out of curiosity? Like, what I
mean by that is, no matter when you try to
talk about guns, they say this is not the time
for politics. We need these direct questions.
That was not some left wing bomb throwing network.
That was Sky News. And now on Friday or Saturday,
Ted Cruz will be at the NRA convention saying,
oh, we got to say a prayer and we've got to make
sure that we keep our right to defend ourselves.
Good job by the sky news reporter And these are
the exact types of questions they need to be asked
and that they would hopefully be forced to answer